when the news broke back in March that
BC had Canada's first death from Kovac
19 in a long-term care home in North
Vancouver just across the water from
here there was fear would BC become the
epicenter of an outbreak in Canada it
could have if it weren't for the quick
and smart response from B C's provincial
health officer the New York Times called
her the top doctor who aced the
coronavirus test dr. Bonnie Henry has
barely had a day off since the beginning
of 2020 and it's her decisive action and
clear calm communication that's kept B
C's numbers low be kind to be calm and
to be safe to be kind to be calm and to
be safe words many NB C live by and
words that have become so popular
there's a cottage industry of Bonnie
Henry merchandise for sale most of the
proceeds going to charity from the start
of the pandemic people connected to her
intelligence and her empathy and
following her advice has saved lives BC
has lost just over a hundred and seventy
people to Kovac 19 Ontario which has
three times the number of people has had
more than 15 times as many deaths and
this is not over the virus has not
vanished and this summer is going to be
another test dr. Bonnie Henry is with me
from Victoria dr. Henry when I first
interviewed you in early April there was
no talk about lifting restrictions case
numbers were still rising now it's
almost July and restrictions are being
lifted in phases almost everywhere and
you say that this will be a unique
summer are you nervous if there's one
thing we've learned about this virus is
that we can't underestimate it and we
have to keep our guard up I think we've
done that really well here in DC so I'm
not sure I'm nervous I do have an
underlying level of anxiety that started
in January that continues but if people
continue to do what we've been able to
do here in BC and you know I'm focusing
on making
sure our public health teams are ready
to do our part as well and we've been
able to do that you know we will see
cases but I believe we can manage that
you're advising people to keep their
bubbles small this summer as Canadians
plan their vacations what do you think
they should aim for not just in BC but
elsewhere in Canada too you know I think
it's really important for us to to take
the summer to have some time to breathe
and to connect with the people that are
important to us in our lives but we also
have a can't lose sight of the fact that
this pandemic is still ongoing so we
need to find that that balance so
keeping small numbers of people where we
would have the big family gathering of
100 150 it needs to be much smaller than
that this year do you think it's likely
that gatherings like big weddings and
funerals and conventions might be too
risky to hold until there's a vaccine
yes I think that unfortunately is the
way it's going to be for the near future
this is not forever but definitely for
the coming months into the fall until we
have either an effective treatment or
vaccine large gatherings like that just
are too risky you know you've got some
power dr. Henry your calm guidance has
made BC a model for the rest of the
world in new york times as you know
calls you the doctor who aced the
coronavirus test and now you've even
told the NHL it has to abide by your
rule so you're not going compromise
those rules so Vancouver can be a hub
for NHL games what's your bottom line on
the NHL I don't know that that's the
particular reason we did have
discussions through the Canucks around
some of the things that I think are
important and you know for me and us
here in public health in the Health
System here focusing on maintaining the
health making sure that we don't
compromise any of the work that we've
put in in these
to protecting our communities here and
it's also important to make sure that
any of the teams the players that came
to BC were also protected so there is no
compromise on that at all let me ask you
about the American border I know it's
not your job to decide whether it
reopens or not but given what you see is
happening in many states the surge in
cases would you want it to open in July
you know we we have had many talks with
our federal counterparts about this I do
think it's important to have family
reunification and we've been supporting
that but no opening for visitors right
now is very risky for us and I think my
colleagues across Canada we all feel
quite strongly about that a
million-dollar question right now is
will there be a second wave what are
your fears about that and what do you
think are our biggest vulnerabilities to
that in Canada right now what I would
like to see in our best-case scenario is
that we continue to grumble along and
control things maybe at some point we
can get it down to no cases in a couple
of days but um you know realistically
looking at what's happened around the
world it's likely that we will see
surges will see small outbreaks as we
have more people who are getting
together and that's why it's so
important for us to keep our numbers of
connections low so that we can find
people quickly that we can do the work
in public health to contain it but we
need to be prepared that when
respiratory season starts we may see an
uptick in both influenza and kovat and
we'll need to be able to manage that to
have the testing capacity and the
contact tracing capacity so that's what
we're planning for for the Fall
and we'll hope for the best but as
somebody has said to me hope is not a
strategy so we need to plan for what
will happen should we start getting more
cases particularly when influenza season
starts where did your mantra be kind be
calm be safe come from it really was a
bit of a compilation you know I was
trying to
figure out how we could get the message
across that we need to be in this
together and we need to understand where
other people are coming from we are in
this storm the same storm but we're not
all in the same boat and by supporting
each other and doing what we need to do
together is how we'll all get through
this storm
[Music]